>> LOOK INTO MY EYESS
YOU WILL SEE.
(LAUGHTER)
I DO IT FOR YOU.
>> DON'T LET THE HORRENDOUS
SINGING DISTRACT YOU FROM THE
FACT THAT THERE IS A
13-YEAR-OLD WEARING A TOMMY
BAHAMA SHIRT.
HE THOUGHT THE BEST WAY TO WOO
THE LOVE OF HIS LIFE WAS TO
MUMBLE A TUNE FROM THE ROBIN
HOOD SOUNDTRACK.
BRYAN ADAMS WOULD BE ROLLING
OVER IN HIS GRAVE IF HE HEARD.
THAT HE IS DEAD, RIIHT?
TOM IS PROOF THAT LIFE BETWEEN
YOUR FIRST BONER AND GETTING
YOUR DRIVER'S LICENSE IS
MAGICAL.
REMEMBER THE FIRST TIME YOU
TOUCHED A PAIR OF BOOB THAT IS
WEREN'T YOUR SISTER'S?
THE PROBLEM IS GIRLS MATURE
FASTER THAN BOYS.
BLACK GUYS ALWAYS REMEMBER
THEIR FIRST CRUSH.
YOU CAN'T FORGET SOMEONE WHEN
YOU LEGALLY HAVE TO WRITE THEM
A CHECK EVERY SINGLE MONTH.
WHEN YOU ARE A KID, LOVE IS SO
EXCITING AND NEW.
YOU CAN CHASE LITTLE GIRLS ON
THE PLAYGROUND AND HOLD THEIR
SKIRTS UP WITHOUT BECOMING A
REGISTERED SEX OFFENDER.%
THAT IS WHY I FLEW TOM TO
HOLLYWOOD WHERE EVERYONE IS IN
LOVE WITH THEMSELVES.
FOR THIS WEEK'S WEB
REDEMPTION.
THANK YOU.
THAT WAS TRULY PAINFUL.
COME ON.
NEXT UP, DOING SOME ROMANTIC
DUETS WITH YOURS TRULY.
GIVE IT UP FOR TOM!
COME ON!
YOU READY TO ROCK THIS PUPPY?
♪ SUMMER LOVIN', HAVING A
BLAST ♪
♪ SUMMER LOVIN', HAPPENED SO
FAST ♪
♪ SAW YOU YESTERDAY WITH AN
OLD FRIEND ♪
♪ I GOT YOU BABE, I GOT YOU
BABE ♪
♪ AIN'T NOTHING BUT A GANGSTER
PARTY ♪
>> OKAY.
DO NOT ENCOURAGE HIM.
TOM, HOW OLD ARE YOU?
>> 13.
>> ARE YOU BIG FOR YOUR AGE?
>> A ITTLE.
>> YOU SEEM BIG FOR 30.
ARE YOU FAN OF BRYAN ADAMS?
MOST 13-YEAR-OLDS AREN'T
FAMILIAR WITH BRYAN ADAMS'
MUSII.
I'M NOT LIKE MOST FANS.
>> NAME ANOTHER SONG.
>> "SUMMER OF '69."
>> TELL ME WHY YOU MADE THE
VIDEO AND...
MY FRIEND TOLD ME SHE LOVED
IT.
>> DO YOU THINK SHE HAS
FEELINGS TOWARD YOU AT ALL?
>> I HAVE NO IDEA.
>> IS THAT WHY YOU ARE GROWING
THE MUSTACHE.%
>> YEAH, A ITTLE.
>> NICE.
YOU THINK YOU WILL ALWAYS LOVE
HER.
>> DEEP DOWN, PROBABLY.
YOU KNOW, YOU NEVER KNOW HOW
THE FUTURE WILL TURN OUT.
>> YOU WANT TO KNOW HOW IT'S
GOING TO TURN OUT?
>> HOW?
>> DEPRESSING.
HOW MANY TAKES DID YOU DO?
>> 30 FOR EACH SCENE.
>> BOY, LET'S STOP THERE.
30 TAKES PER SCENE?
SO YOU ARE TELLING ME THERE IS
A MUCH WORSE VERSION OF THIS
THAT YOU COULD HAVE PUT OUT?
>> YES.
(LAUGHTER)
>> WHAT'S THE NUMBER ONE THING
YOU FIND ATTRACTIVE?
>> HOW MUCH THEY ACTUALLY
CARE.
>> HOW MUCH DO YOU KNOW ABOUT
PSYCHOLOGY?
>> ENOUGH TO GET BY IN LIE.
>> WHERE DO YOU THINK A GOOD
PLACE TO MEET WOMEN IS?
>> IT DEPENDS ON THE SCENARIO.
>> YOU ARE SPEAKING IN VAGUE
CLICHES.
FAVORITE MOVIE?
>> BATTLESHIP.
MOVIE?TLESHIP YOUR FAVORITE
>> YES.
>> I HAD SO MUCH RESPECT FOO
YOU FOR THIS ENTIRE INTERVIEW.
RIGHT NOW IF YOUR FATHER
WASN'T SITTING OVER THERE, I
WOULD ATTACK YOU.
IF.
>> IT IS ABOUT THE NAVY.
>> IT IS ABOUT A STUPID WAR
GAME THAT EVERY KID CHEATED
AT.
>> HOW ABOUT FLIRTING WITH
YOUR FRIENDS?
>> THAT IS A HORRIBLE IDEA.
>> DO OFF JOB IN.
>> NO.
>> HOW DO YOU PLAN ON TAKING
HER OUT ANYWAY?
>> THE MONEY I GET FOR THIS.
(LAUGHTER)
>> NICE WE ARE CONTRIBUTING.
YOU ARE NOT A SUPER-STRONG
VOCALIST.
WE WILL COME UP WITH A NEW
APPROACH.
>> FAIR ENOUGH.
>> I WANT WITNESSED WHEN HER
YOU READY TO WIN HER BACK?
>> YES.
>> WOMEN LOVER A SENSE OF
HUMOR.
SAY SOMETHING FUNNY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
I DON'T REMEMBER.
>> DO SOME YOUR MOMMA JOKES.
>> I CAN'T USE THIS ONE.
>> TRY A DIFFERENT ONE.
>> YOUR MOM ACTION IS SO DUMB
SHE PUTS ON BUG SPRAY BEFFRE
SHE GOES TO THE FLEA MARKET.
NEEDS A MACH-500 RAZOR.
>> NONE OF THIS IS WORKING,
DAN.
>> SHOW HER HOW STRONG AND
ASSERTIVV YOU ARE.
>> IF YOU DON'T COME DOWN HERE,
I'M GOING TO MURDER YOUR
FAMILY.
>> WAY TOO ASSERTIVE.
WHY ARE YOU GROWLING?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> ALL RIGHT.
NONE OF THIS IS WORKING.
NO GIRLS CAN RESIST A SEXY
VAMPIRE.
(LAUGHTER)
COUNT CHOCULA WORKS.
TAKE THESE.
YOU ARE GOING TO NEED THEM..3
DON'T FORGET TO SHOW YOU THE
SUGARY CARBS.
NICE..3
>> IT'' A TRAP!
RUN!
>> THIS IS ALL A BIG
MISUNDERSTOODING.